[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here welcome
back to quarantine content just a little
entertainment for you while we're all
staying inside i'm your host marquez
brownlee and uh you might have heard by
now that apple was selling these wheels
for the mac pro you remember that clip
at the end of our mac pro review of it
just kind of rolling away because
there are no locks yeah those wheels now
on the surface it's not actually clear
why anyone would actually need wheels to
their computer considering your computer
just sits at your desk anyway but hey
you know what there's nothing wrong with
selling a product that very few people
actually need but they are a 400 option
when you configure them alongside the
new mac pro and if you don't do that you
decide you want them later for some
reason you can buy them to install
yourself separately for
seven
hundred
dollars seven
hundred
dollars
for these wheels
i have some thoughts so there's a lot of
reactions i could give a lot of things i
could say about these wheels about how
ridiculous they are
how stupid they are how insulting it
would be that they would even offer that
but i decided to take a step back and
actually try to consider why
they exist in the first place now as you
saw by the unboxing i actually have the
wheels and
i gotta say having them in person which
very few people obviously do
there are some really nice wheels
objectively these might be the nicest
computer wheels i've ever seen now i
don't know about you but when i think of
computer wheels i'm thinking of like the
dusty plastic like those standard
casters you see in schools
these wheels are complete and total
overkill uh they're entirely metal and
rubber and you can tell as soon as you
pick one up it's hefty like there's
weight to it how much weight you might
be asking well one wheel weighs more
than twice an iphone 11 pro so you can
tell it's basically solid metal they
come with this metal dual sided hex tool
with a black rubberized sleeve around
the middle for grip that just says
china
there's also two nearly identical
installation guides in the box for some
reason but one of them with more
languages than the other why would they
make two of these instead of just
printing it all on one
i don't know and the wheels themselves
they fully articulate 360 degrees at
every joint so the top joint rotates
totally around and also says china on
the top of it and then there's two fully
independent fully articulate super
smooth rubber treads so kind of like a
car with torque vectoring it can create
an even tighter turning radius than if
it was a one-sided single tire so all
that being said are these wheels
actually good to cost 700
no of course not still if this if this
piece of metal with tiny microchips and
ram and a motherboard and batteries and
cameras and software tying it all
together and the screen
costs 400
then the material cost is clearly not
there but you know sometimes you can
argue the value of something is higher
based on the value it delivers to the
person who buys it
but still the value of these wheels is
just putting the mac pro
on wheels with no brakes and the mac pro
has to be plugged into the wall to be on
anyway so
that argument doesn't really work really
the only reasonable argument you can
come up with having actually seen these
is okay these are such high quality
wheels that the tooling required to make
them cost so much
and the volume that they're going to
sell is so low that they have to price
them super high to make their money back
on selling these wheels but apple
doesn't need to make their money back on
every single product they make they
regularly don't do that and they often
subsidize their less successful products
with their more successful ones so why
would apple make
these
700 wheels if they know that
the answer i think
to keep their shine see apple
loves to keep this image of a premium
luxury brand it's what allows them to
charge more for a lot of stuff but
everyone knows every every luxury
brand's got some luxury products that
you know are so expensive that people
aren't really mad that they can't get it
but it's super easy to make fun of we
see this with brands we talk about all
the time supreme
gucci
rolex bugatti you know there's a ton of
them and no matter what you think of
them you've heard of them and you know
what they stand for now let's be
perfectly clear apple is a tech company
obviously but in this tech world
they are the luxury one and keeping that
status keeping that perceived image of
high quality
isn't easy that that doesn't just come
effortlessly you know they're in a
competitive tech world where other
companies are throwing their absolute
best at them and trying to make their
best possible products and make as much
money as they possibly can and so that
competitive landscapes crafted the likes
of the 329 ipad which is an incredible
deal in the tablet world and of course
the recent 400 iphone se that's super
competitive again one of the best deals
ever from their camp so they're not
allergic to pricing things competitively
especially when it benefits their
business but on the other end of the
spectrum to keep their premium luxury
image
they of course need high priced products
see this is something i've talked about
in some previous apple related videos
because as much products as they do make
i've wished that they would make more to
fill in the gaps because often in some
categories they will choose to keep up
their image they will choose to just
make the expensive version of that thing
like when making a desktop tower
computer
they only make one
and they made the expensive one now
there are many things that can change
the perceived quality of an item you
know the actual hardware quality and fit
and finish and materials
and even the name and the design of the
packaging but the price is also one of
those things there have been studies
done and i'll try to link one of them
below
where you put two essentially identical
things next to each other
and price one item higher than the other
and if you ask people which they think
is the better higher quality item
they'll pick the more expensive one
people literally just assume with no
other context that the higher priced
item is better but here's the thing
competition
is brutal especially in tech so you
can't just raise all of your prices
across the board and then boom suddenly
you're a luxury company it's not that
easy so apple is uniquely positioned in
a way where they can be competitive
where it matters
but then they can also on the other end
sacrifice some products for the memes in
the name of keeping up their luxury
status
and
i guess why not make something extreme
while you're at it linus from minus tech
tips made a great video touching on a
lot of this which i'll link below where
he also brings up another great point
tell me if you've heard this before
media attention
all press is good press virtually every
article written about the mac pro's
crazy wheels mention other apple
products shed light on the mac pro and
on apple's history sometimes literally
even list a couple other apple products
that you could buy for the same price as
those wheels so you can see how it feels
like all press is a good press so apple
can choose to make that sacrifice with
certain products and the mac pros wheels
that's a perfect set that's a perfect
place to sacrifice were you gonna buy
these anyway if they were if they were
200 bucks if these were 25 bucks were
you gonna buy the mac pros wheels
no so this is a perfect no-brainer you
know what else is a no-brainer the
thousand dollar monitor stand
the 300
coffee table book the 17 000
gold apple watch so while pretty much no
one in their right mind should buy any
of these
it makes perfect sense that they exist
and the more you talk about and comment
about their crazy 700 wheels
the more apple kind of just gets exactly
what they want
more attention
unless it's this video either way that's
been it thanks for watching hope you
learned something and uh i guess i gotta
go find something to attach these wheels
to now to feel like i
spent them for good reason
it's probably not gonna happen but
either way the merch also by the way is
also on sale all those links that i
talked about are below the like button
check them out thanks again for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace